are you familiar with michael saylor
uh he's the crypto guy he's a crypto guy
yeah i take a cop out on crypto they say
if you don't understand crypto that
means you're old i'm 78 i don't
understand crypto i don't want to say
it's a fraud i think blockchain
technology is for real i don't
understand crypto
i i got a couple million bucks for the
money manager it has a four percent
position so i got eighty thousand
dollars in crypto
you got eighty thousand dollars in
crypto yeah that's right so that's two
bitcoins give or take
two and a half million dollars
two bitcoin i i know nothing about it i
don't have an intelligent view
i know smart people on both sides so me
too and i'm and i'm uh uh i own a pos i
have a position in bitcoin and ethereum
but um i a person wouldn't call me like
oh this guy's a you know full-on but i
have michael saylor here the other day
and one guy seems like a very smart guy
well you said education i said so why
are you doing these things this is only
one reason i got to educate people i got
educated about by why bitcoin makes
sense the one part that uh
more and more i think about it more and
more i think about what's going on is
when when what took place with ukraine
and uh russia what's going on right now
over there right well what happened with
canada the whole truckers what they were
doing
they can shut down your checking account
if they wanted to they can shut down
your credit cards they can shut down
access to a lot of that stuff i can't
send gold to you my family in iran and
say hey you're going through tough times
here in 30 seconds i'm gonna send you
gold i can't set that if if
the direction of how exchange can take
place the blockchain technology as well
as bitcoin or ethereum that's making
more and more sense
for the younger audience and some of the
older guys are starting to say maybe
this does make sense but charlie munger
came out and which rat poison yeah he
calls the bread poison that's what he
yeah he can say whatever he wants he did
not say good things about uh
bitcoin i was more in line with him but
the truth is i've learned over the years
you speak about things you know
something about i i don't know enough
about it charlie is a very bright guy
and he speaks his mind
jimmy diamond has said things about it
warren buffett said things about it
i don't i don't think it's in the
interest of the us dollar to
the u.s country to promote an
alternative currency
um
but it may emerge on its own who knows
do you have control over that that's
free marketing right the market i think
they've missed their chance there's
trillions of dollars now held in this
stuff so that out laura they'll just tax
it to death that's all they'll they'll
they'll basically have adverse taxes on
uh bitcoin if you enjoyed this short
clip click over here to watch another
short clip and if you want to watch the
entire episode the entire podcast click
here
[Music]